foreign  [Music]  thank you  [Music]  we're ready to defend  defense why is it necessary to have the  101st year we bring a unique capability  for a light infantry Force but again we  bring that Mobility through our aircraft  and our air assaults  [Music]  we're roughly 20 miles away from Snake  Island this contentious Island that's  been fought over between the ukrainians  and the Russians currently under  Ukrainian control  foreign  [Music]  for me to have the American troops here  is like if you were to have allies in  Normandy before any enemy was there  foreign  [Music]  you've had an opportunity to to watch  observe  possibly study  the Russians what do you think of them  so far so we're uh we're closely  watching them so we're building  objectives to practice against that  replicate exactly what's going on in  Ukraine we're the closest American unit  to be fighting in Ukraine and what does  that feel like what does that mean it uh  it keeps the Sun keeps us on our toes  right